في بولندا اعلن وزير الداخليه اعتقال
روسيين اثنين بتهمه توزيع منشورات دعائيه
تروج لصالح مجموعه باجنر العسكريه الروسيه
وتدعو للانضمام اليها في وارسو وكاراكوف
اكبر مدينه في البلاد وذكرت وكاله مكافحه
التجسس البولنديه ان الرجلين اعتقل يوم
الجمعه بعد ان وزع نحو 300 منشور في اماكن
عامه في كراكوف وارسو واكدت بولندا قد
كانت بولندا قد عبرت عن قلقها ازاء عمل
استفزازيا محتمل من قبل مقاتل فاجنر
المتمركزه حاليا في بيلاروسيا المجاوره
التفاصيل عبد القادر جاء بها المدعي العام
البولندي قال بان الروسيين المعتقلين كان
يخططان لمغادره بولندا يوم الخميس اي
اعتقل يوم الجمعه بمعنى انهم اعتقل عشيه
مغادره البلد يقول بان العناصر من
الاستخبارات الداخليه هي التي قامت
باعتقالهما كان يقومان بانشطه لصالح
الاستخبارات الروسيه ايضا قال بان
المعتقلين قام بانشطه دعائيه في بولندا
بطلب من الاستخبارات الروسيه اضاف بان
المعتقلين كان على التواصل مع الاجهزه
الامنيه الروسيه تحديدا الاستخبارات وقال
بان المعتقلين ايضا وجهت لهم تهمه القيام
بانشطه استخباراتيه لجهه خارجيه من اجل
ضرب مصالح بولندا اضاف بانهما ينتميان الى
جمعيه اجراميه دوليه محظوره وقال بان
الانتماء الى هذه جمعيه الدوليه
المنظمه الاجراميه كان يهدف الى
ارتكاب جرائم ذات طابع ارهابي وقال بان
هذه او هذين المعتقلين يعملان لصالح منظمه
للمرتزقه محظوره وفق القانون الدولي على
حد تعبيره الان ماذا سيكون مصيرهما حسب
المدعي العامه عبد القادر فانهما يخدعان
الان
للحبسه الاحتياطي وقد اضاف ايضا بانه عثر
على لديهم عن كميات هامه من المنشورات
الدعائيه الى ذلك لا يزال الموضوع هو
الوضع التوتر خلفي هنا على الحدود بين
بيلاروسيا وبولندا كنا في الحقيقه رصدنا
الاجواء قبل ايام نفس الوضع من حين لاخر
قبل ظهور معك عبد القادر كانت هناك طياره
طائره هليكوبتر في السماء تحوم حول هذه
البوابه تعرف جيدا في الايام القليله
الماضيه كانت السلطات البولنديه اتهمت
بيلاروسيا
يعني بالتحليق
بواسطه طائرتي هليكوبتر على الحدود
البولنديه هناك توتر هذا التوتر ركز عليه
رئيس الوزراء في مقابله اجراها قبل نهايه
هذا الاسبوع مع صحيفه الايطاليه قال بان
ما يجري من توتر في هذه المنطقه سببه
التنسيق كما قال بين بيلاروسيا وروسيا
واضافها عندما سئل هل فاجنر تشكل خطرا
بتواجدها على الحدود هنا خلفي على بولندا
قال لقد راينا وشاهدنا ماذا حققت وماذا
فعلت فاجنر في افريقيا وفي اوكرانيا واضيف
الى ذلك بانه في الاجواء الاحتفاليه غدا
كما تعلم عبد القادر هناك استعراض عسكري
كبير اعلن وزير الدفاع عن ايضا صفقه جديده
لتزويد الجيش البولندي العتاد الحديث كما
قال
شكرا لك نور الدين ابو زياد كنت بعمل
الحدود البولنديه البيلاروسيه شكرا جزيلا
لك